[Music]
it's fun to dress up your elf princess
but if you're looking for an online game
that'll put some hair on your chest
let's take a look at ten incredibly
badass online games first mechanical
commando a top-down shooter that asks
why would you ever let go of the trigger
if you're more of a nature lover go
fishing but not like a [ __ ] in this
game you reel in fish flip him in the
air and shoot them with a shotgun I
think this is how Red Lobster does it if
you're more of a military strategist
here's a tower defense game where you
pick and place your defense it's not the
best one I've ever played but the
enemies are zombies if you'd rather play
as a zombie zombie bites is a cute
little game where you eat people to stay
alive but watch out for zombie hunters
and be careful because everyone you eat
becomes a zombie you have to compete
with sticking to the zombie theme zombie
golf riot is nice and simple you aim
with your mouse and then swing with your
mouse and the golf ball is a zombie's
head to cuban things up let's talk about
penguins they're nice and mild but give
them Izzie's and baseball bats and
you've got penguins with a Z this
curious Weltman might seem cuddly but
over the win you have to eat the
parasites your mother vomits down on you
and shoot the evil guys by barfing up
your own blood if you want something
more calculated try tactical assassin
substratum you'll be given specific
instructions and elite a steady hand and
MA these are the magical fruit but they
can also be gangsta bee and finally try
Kelkar to revenge you've got to finish
laps but also run over shoot and launch
missiles Plus as you earn money you can
upgrade your car and customize its look
you can play all of these games right
now by following links in this video's
description and let me know in the
comments below what is the most badass
thing you've ever done I can't wait to
hear your answers I've got a special
episode of IMG coming up this weekend
but for now use this grid to watch other
V lists and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]
you